violences à 750 milliards d'euros pour
l'union européenne la commission de
bruxelles a présenté son plan pour
répondre avec les u coronavirus il fait
la part belle aux subventions et
favorise les pays les plus touchés comme
l'italie et l'espagne
ce plan qui s'inspire en grande partie
des propositions françaises et
allemandes peut-il remporter l'adhésion
des plus réfractaires comme les pays-bas
ou l'autriche est il à la hauteur de la
récession historique qui nous attend on
voit cela avec vous jacques sapir
bonsoir jacques alors jacquet bonsoir
c'est fait des bonds soir cette réponse
de la part de lieux qui tarn et en est
elle au niveau des espérances et surtout
des besoins jacques
non absolument pas vous savez ici on
compare avec ce que font par exemple les
autres grands pays que ce soit la chine
où que ce soit les états unis et bien
les sommes qui sont tant que sont très
faibles pour l'union européenne on est
actuellement autour de 3 % du pib alors
qu'on est entre 7 et 10% pour le plan de
relance seulement se parle pas des des
plans d'accompagnement de la crise née
pour le plan de relance mans on est
entre 7 et 10% du pib en chine et aux
états unis
alors oui on voit bien il ya un gros
problème maintenant le plan franco
allemand qui a été présentée le lundi 18
mai eh bien il propose 540 milliards ce
qui n'est pas rien évidemment puisque ça
viendrait s'ajouter aux 500 milliards
qui était déjà prévu mais ses 540
milliards
eh bien il va s'agir essentiellement de
transferts budgétaires puisque c'est de
l'argent que la commission de bruxelles
les vrais directement sur les marchés le
problème c'est qu'évidemment cette
proposition a provoqué une crispation
chez les pays du nord ce qu'on appelle
les quatre frugaux la hollande la suède
le danemark vraiment et l'autriche et
que évidemment et bien on est parti dans
une attente d'un cycle de négociations
on peut même parler qu'on est parti pour
un nouveau cycle des faux semblant alors
jacques commençons par la proposition
franco-allemande fait avant ce plan de
relance de quoi s'agissait-il faut
savoir que cette proposition
c'était déjà un compromis là
france elle voulait un plan à 1500
milliards
l'allemagne a dit non mais elle a
accepté et ça c'est un point
effectivement très important elle a
accepté une forme de mutualisation des
dettes ce qu'elle avait complètement
refusé auparavant
alors ce plan de 500 milliards c'est de
l'argent qui viendra d'un endettement de
la commission européenne cet argent sera
redistribué aux pays qui en ont le plus
besoin il sera redistribuée sous la
forme de subventions budgétaires ce qui
équivaut en faire quasiment des dons et
puis bien entendu au niveau du
remboursement et bien si jamais ces
sommes sont remboursés parce qu'il n'est
pas du tout sûr qu'elles soient
remboursées bien si jamais ces sommes
doivent être un jour rembourser elles le
seront essentiellement par des
contributions au budget
ce qui veut dire que ce nouvel
endettement ne viendra pas s'inscrire
dans l'endettement déjà pris par ces
différents pays
ça ne viendra pas sur le fameux ratio
dette sur piles qui est si important
pour certains pays on pense notamment à
l'italie
pourtant cette proposition jacques n'a
pas fait plaisir à tout le monde
oh que non stéphanie haut que non et
bien si vous voulez donc les les quatre
pays que j'ai cité est ce qu'on appelle
les quatre offres hugo ont immédiatement
réagi au delà il faut voir qu'il ya
peut-être une maladresse dans la manière
dans ce plan a été présenté parce que à
faire un plan entre la france et
l'allemagne à ne pas s'associer d'autres
pays qui sont des pays importants
l'italie 3e
maintenant c'est là c'est la troisième
économie de l'union européenne l'espagne
voire la belgique
ou le portugal à ne pas associer ces
pays et on a donné l'impression que ben
voilà il y avait des pays qui étaient
plus égaux que d'autres pour reprendre
la phrase d'orwell et que la france et
l'allemagne voulait gouverner
l'union européenne alors au delà de
cette maladresse et bien il est clair
qu'il ya une opposition des pays dits
frugaux qui vraiment rejette la
dynamique globale de ce plan alors ces
pays dits frugaux ans comme vous dites
que propose-t-il ces pays et c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre
d'un côté ils sont tout à fait d'accord
sur l'idée d'un fonds de relance et qui
serait là lié aux circonstances tout à
fait exceptionnelles que nous vivons
c'est pas là dessus que se posent
l'essentiel du problème eux ce qu'ils
proposent c'est que on est un plan qui
soit en fait fondés sur des prêts
ponctuelle aux pays qui en ont le plus
besoin
d'ailleurs c'est un point important il
ne mentionne aucune somme donc ça c'est
déjà un point qu'il faut relever et
c'est si vous laissez près ponctuelles
et bien il servirait évidemment à faire
des investissements dans les secteurs
qui en ont le plus besoin
évidemment l'économie verte la recherche
l'innovation mais il serait soumis à
l'engagement ferme pris par les pays qui
contracteraient évidemment un cdh est
donc cet engagement ferme à mettre en
oeuvre des réformes et à rester de
manière absolument strict dans les clous
de l'orthodoxie budgétaire et en quoi
jackass différent de la proposition
franco allemande alors alors une
première différence évidente un hymne et
plus du tout question de dette
mutualisée et là on voit très bien c'est
une rupture avec ce que veulent ou ce
que voudrait paris et berlin
et puis il ya un autre problème c'est
que si vous voulez ce plan et bien il
fait référence aux grands principes
fondamentaux de l'union européenne et
ses principes fondamentaux ce sont
exactement les mêmes que ceux qui sous
tendent le fameux mécanisme
si vous le mécanisme européen de
stabilité le ms
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire pour les pays qui contracteraient
des dettes dans ce cadre
eh bien ça veut dire se mettre sous la
coupe de la troïka se mettre dans la
même situation qu on était le portugal
la grèce voire l'espagne
de plus et c'est un point important les
quatre frugaux ne veulent pas que ce
plan de relance soit d'une certaine
manière pour l'éternité
ils demandent que la période soit
réduite à deux ans et ils demandent
surtout qu'il y ait une évaluation du
risque financier que ceux ci ferait
prendre à la commission alors elles sont
pour les desiderata malheureusement non
ces pays ont même d'autres exigences
alors ils ont des exigences très nette
en ce qui concerne le budget européen
vous savez qu'on va devoir rediscuter du
budget européen sur la période 2021 et
2027 d'ailleurs à cause de la crise que
nous vivons actuellement est là encore
il demande à ce que ce soit des règles
d'austérité et des règles de frugalité
qui prévalent
il considère qu'il est dangereux que les
pays de l'union européenne
je dirais s'habitue à des budgets trop
important et pour en revenir jacques au
plan de la zone relance de la commission
comment compellent le financer alors
c'est un point intéressant la commission
européenne a fait mercredi à dernier a
fait des propositions qui d'ailleurs
s'inspire assez largement des
propositions qui avaient été faites par
la france et l'allemagne
là encore il s'agirait d'un emprunt que
prendrait directement la commission
alors le point qui est un petit peu
important le point qui tranche
peut-être dans cette pro pendant cette
proposition de la commission par rapport
à la proposition franco allemand sait qu
on devra les plus importantes
grosso modo 750 milliards mais elle est
divisée en deux il ya d'une part 500
milliards qui seraient en réalité des
fonds budgétaires et là on retrouve la
mécanique qui était celle du plan franco
allemand et puis il ya 250 milliards qui
seraient plutôt des prêts accordés aux
différents pays
alors
le point sur lequel il faut peut-être
bien revenir c'est le fait que la
commission exige en réalité que les
priorités politiques qu'elle a fixés en
particulier la transition écologique que
ce qu'on appelle le fameux green deal
que ses priorités politiques soient
respectés et d'autre part il est clair
qu'elle veut avancer sur cette idée de
mutualisation des dettes alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que il
n'ya pas là de deux points de compromis
entre ce que propose des quatre frigo
est ce que propose la commission que
donc les débats vont être houleux et
qu'il faudra de nombreuses réunions du
conseil européen pour pouvoir avancer
sur cette question si tenté que l'on
avance
mais jacques voyez-vous tout de même
avec tout ce que vous nous dites à un
compromis avec ces quatre pays et 4 go
bah si vous voulez je pense qu'un
compromis est d'une certaine manière
inévitable mais il est très clair que on
est en présence une opposition forte de
la part de ces cas pays et il faut
rappeler que s'il n'ya pas l'unanimité
ça ne peut pas s'ils voulaient ces
propositions ne peuvent pas se
concrétiser dans un port
qu'est ce que pourraient être les bases
un compromis très certainement de
renforcer le contrôle de la commission
sur le budget des pays qui prendrait de
l'argent qu'ils obtiendraient de
l'argent à travers les différents
mécanismes peut-être une réduction de
l'endettement général de la commission
bref on irait plutôt dans je dirais le
domaine d'un plus grand contrôle sur les
sommes qui seraient à ce moment là à
utiliser et ça c'est un point que
l'espagne et surtout l'italie semble
vouloir refuser absolument
donc voilà on est parti pour un débat et
une négociation qui sera extrêmement
difficile pour résumé jacques si on vous
lit bien vous n'êtes phare optimiste et
hélas non et je dois dire que je
voudrais est trop petit mais si vous
regardez grosso modo les sommes qui sont
en cause avec le plan franco allemand on
est grosso modo au tour
mille milliards d'euros avec le plan de
la commission 12150 si on regarde le
plan de relance qui a été déjà acté
aux etats unis ses 2300 milliards
or l'économie américaine elle est en
fait plus petit que l'économie de
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne donc déjà là il ya un
problème tout à fait évident et je passe
évidemment sur la question des
négociations qui seront comme je voulais
dit extrêmement difficile en fait la
solution qui aurait été la plus
rationnelle et certainement la plus
facile à mettre en oeuvre
c'était la solution qui consistait à
dire aux pays-bas écoutez vous faites
les plans dont vous avez besoin ne va
pas regarder ce que vous faites est
votre endettement et bien c'est
directement la banque centrale
européenne qui le reprend oui mais
malheureusement il y à l'arrêt du 5 mai
de la cour de karlsruhe qui est venu
d'une certaine manière faire capoter
je dirais tout cette belle mécanique et
c'est peut-être pour ça que l'on est
aujourd'hui rentré dans cette logique de
propositions qui devront être âprement
discutés dans plusieurs conseils
européens
merci jacques pour toutes ces
explications qui nous donne à réfléchir
merci à vous et à bientôt et à bientôt
sur rt france